hello louis
hey movie how's it going
i'm it's going great how about you
yeah good it's uh today it's snowing
like crazy so
it's a nice day to be doing question
answering
yeah a great day too every day is great
to do question answering
so yeah
um
so for the first session
like
this is a concept where we have come up
with uh to
make the like make every session we are
going to go through a course chapter
of uh task this one is for question
answering next one might be in masked
language modeling you can decide it
on our discord
and
our discord is let me
let me bring up the banner uh hf dot co
slash join slash discord and today we
are going to go over the course chapter
on question answering you can ask your
questions from here
let's get started
awesome so i thought what we could do
today
is focus a lot on more the sort of
conceptual aspects and the data
processing side of this problem because
that the training of the model is in
some sense the easiest part in question
answering and it's actually how do we
prepare the data um
thanks to transformers
exactly yes so so i'm not going to
probably train a model per se today
because i think that's um kind of once
you get to that point it's pretty much
just feeding it to the trainer and
you're done
um but you know maybe it's nice to um
just start by kind of like asking
ourselves like what is question
answering
and and maybe what it looks like in the
real world
so i've got a couple of cartoons here
um maybe you can see this one um on
screen
so
most of the time like when we talk about
question answering in nlp it actually
means many different things
so for example
the question answering that we're
looking at today is something called
extractive question answering
because the answer that we're looking
for in the document can be extracted
directly from the document itself
but there's other things like for
example
generative question answering where you
use a model like i'm bart or gpt2 or
something like this and you try to
generate an answer
based on some input prompt and so these
these kind of examples are quite
different from each other in flavor
and um when you want to actually build
question answering systems in the real
world
building the model is is just one small
part of the problem and
um most systems today that i know of
they they use what's called a retriever
reader system
so you actually have a retriever which
takes a question from some person so
someone here is asking when did mary
curie when her first nobel prize
and this retriever is kind of like a
search engine so you can think of it as
like elasticsearch or any other you know
tf idf would also be perfectly fine
and then this this search engine will
just
look through your database because you
might have millions of documents to find
the ones that are most kind of relevant
for the query
and then these are the documents that
are then fed to a model which is
typically a transformer and then the
transformer will basically pass these
documents and try to extract uh the most
uh probable answer so in this case
the model says you know mary curie got
her second or her first nobel prize in
1903.
so
in the in the
very basic terms question answering
models take documents
and the question and actually look for
the answer in those questions
in those documents right like the very
basic idea is and
this is
where
extractive question answering takes
place where we know
that the
the um we can extract the exact answer
very sorry exact answer from
the documents
as opposed to do generative question
answering where the answer is generated
not extracted so it is going to say
something like
merry
curry won her
first nobel prize at 19 uh three
something like that
uh instead of saying directly saying the
year extracted from the sentence
exactly exactly right
and there's actually there's even other
more interesting flavors that you might
see so if you go to amazon um
let's say amazon.d
or actually sorry i'll do the english
one
if i go to the german one no one will
understand it okay so if you look up a
product like i don't know a les paul
guitar
um so these are like super beautiful
guitars and you know maybe let's pick
one that has a lot of stars like this
well this is not less pool but whatever
so what you can often see on amazon
is um they have a kind of question
answering system so if you look up here
people ask questions does it come with a
bag or a whammy and then someone from
the community
then has answered it and so this type of
question answering is called community
question answering because you're kind
of asking questions and getting answers
from people in the community
and in this case instead of trying to
extract the answer from some text what
you're trying to do is if i have a new
question i try to find the most similar
answer in my in my um database and so in
this case you might use something that's
more like a like a sort of embedding
approach where you would embed the
questions and the answers and you do
like a semantic search type thing like
sentence similarity sort of exactly
yeah
exactly so you would say okay if i have
a question which is asking about this
gig bag i would embed this as a vector
and then if i have a new question
um that is similar then i would try to
see you know which answer is most
similar to that question and um this is
how for example when i type here like um
let's say i don't know
something about
you know
does it come with strings or something
[Music]
then you can see that it's trying to
find the most common
questions and you know in this case
it isn't a good answer but you get the
general idea
i've actually used this once because i
kind of found the my my problem was hard
so i instead i thought that i could
actually solve it like this because like
this actually
works fine with
you know when you are not looking for
exact answer but maybe the cons context
that your answer might
be
existing in
you know what i mean yeah like if even
if it's not the exact answer like you
get something similar uh that you know
your answer is possibly in this sentence
which is actually good like
the model is trying its best and i
appreciate it
yeah and and one thing is like this is
much easier to label because you know
provided you've already got um kind of a
question answering like forum or um
system like this one
then you don't actually have to go and
check
you know the answer exists precisely in
the document you can just sort of um
yeah
you know kind of bootstrap the model on
the um community um
question answering
yeah like
we need to like mention that
the question answering models
actually expect data with
with their star start and the end index
indices of where the answer is in the
actual context and the question and the
context itself so maybe for this case we
don't actually need it so which is as
you said is easy to
you know easy to do
easy to label
you are not even labeling i guess
exactly exactly and so yeah just just to
sort of like set the scene and you know
follow what you were saying is like if
we now focus on just this extractive
question answering task which is the one
in the in the course
then
what you can see here is exactly what
merv i mentioned so
we have
a question so this is the start here
where we say this is the question
and then we have what is called the
context which is typically the document
where we think the answer would live so
this is all this stuff here which says
this is the context with blah blah blah
and the answer
um in general lives somewhere in this
context and the thing that we need to do
is to predict the start and end of of
this some span of tokens or span of
words where this answer lives
and
almost all of the work in question
answering or this extracted form of
question answering is how do you process
your documents and your questions so
that you can
you know identify precisely these um
these starts and ends
and so
maybe with that we could start having a
look at some some of the code from the
course and then we can switch between
you know slides and courses we go yeah
of course
[Music]
okay so
if you want to follow along um you can
just hit this open in collab button on
the course here and then this will open
up
the collab either in pytorch or
tensorflow based on your
preferred framework
and um
in this particular
chapter we're using something called the
squad data set
or the stanford
maybe in you know uh in the hacking
phase hub there is a there is data set
viewer and
like it's best if we
show it there because it looks nice
let's do that let's see let's use it so
if you go to
um
huggingface.com you go to the datasets
tab here
you can then search for squad
and
there are two versions of squad i'll
explain what they are in a sec but the
one we're using today is uh the first
version of squad
and then you'll get like a little kind
of sample of elements here but you can
also go to this data set viewer link
here
and this will then show you kind of in a
full screen what we've got
so here we've got a couple of splits
we've got a train and validation split
and what we can see is
each of the examples has an id
[Music]
we have a title about the document
we have this context where the answer
might live and then we have the question
and the
extracted answers
so if i click on one of these rows
what i expect will happen is it will
expand yep and so now we can actually
see you know the full text
associated with this example
so this data set this squad data set um
it's a very famous uh data set that was
developed at stanford and what they did
is they took
documents from wikipedia in english
and they then um
basically chunked them into passages so
kind of like paragraph length um sort of
segments and then in each one of those
segments they um they annotated
um you know
a question about that segment and then
whether or not an answer um existed or
not and so you can see in this example
here
this is a piece of text about i think uh
the virgin mary and i guess some
miracles
so the question says you know to whom
did the virgin mary appear in 1858 in
lured a france
and so
you know as a human you would probably
read this text and you would go
where is it where is it and then we can
say oh
um
something let's see
san bernadette somewhere that's right so
we can see yeah
you know it is a replica of the grotto
of lourdes france where the version of
mary repeatedly appeared to saint
bernadette in 1858
and so you can see that the the label is
indeed saint bernadette subarus and
we're told here that the answer is sort
of 515
and what that means is that if we just
look at all the characters
um in this in this document once we get
to character 515 that's the start of of
the answer and then we just have to
add the length of the answer itself to
get the end
based on this text
and so this task is often called reading
comprehension because
it's um even though it's based on like
you know asking questions and extracting
answers
um it's it's also very similar to what
you do in school you know when you're
you're asked to read some essay and then
you have a bunch of questions about that
essay it's a very similar kind of task
and so yeah the one thing i wanted to
point out if we go to um there's a
website called papers with code
um which is great if you want to see
kind of like what is the current state
of the art and i think if we look at
squad
[Music]
um i guess we're looking at squad one
let's maybe look at this one
so they they have a bunch of tables that
are quite interesting maybe this
exactly yeah
so you can actually see like the the
progress over time um for for this
particular data set and there are two
kind of metrics that are used one is
called exact match which is where you
check that the predicted answer is
exactly the same
as the um
extracted one or the ground truth
and there's also an f1 score which is
kind of like a variation of the f1 score
you get in classification tasks
and um
you know what you can see not so easily
now because you know transformers are
taking over
but there was like quite a big jump in
performance
from
the time before
transformer models so you can see here
that the exact match score was around 67
points
and then you know now we look at
transformers like luke and you're
getting around 90
points in exact match
and so
this is one of the sort of famous
benchmarks which made like the whole
field kind of go wow
when burke came along because bert was
one of the big jumps you can see here
of 87
and you know the previous models okay
they were they were similar but they
were based on you know ensembles and so
here we had a single model that was um
the state of the art at the time
okay so
so we're using this uh squad data set
and um you can get this from the hub as
we saw um just by just feeding in the
squad the name of the data set to load
data set function
and this uh object we get back is kind
of like a dictionary in python where we
have splits so we've got a train and
validation split
and each one of these splits is now this
like data set object which you probably
have seen in other sections of the
course
and so
we can index into these objects sort of
like as a normal um python kind of
container and you can see that you know
we have the context we saw before this
is the story about the virgin mary um
appearing to someone and we can see you
know here here are the kind of
um
text data that we're dealing with
and there's also a validation set um
which has um you know different topics
and the goal that we want to do
is we want to process these
inputs in such a way
that
when we're provided with
new
examples for example in the validation
set
the model will actually predict
the the start and end
indices for where the answer could be
okay so
maybe we can have a look at
the preprocessing and
before we do that it might make sense to
just have a kind of look at what we mean
by
you know
what what is the model actually doing
and also trying to understand like what
we actually want to extract from the
data
so
this is kind of a kind of simplified
cartoon of what the the model looks like
for question answering
so you you typically have like an
encoder
layer which is very similar to anything
you've you've seen with burt
and other models
and this encoder
takes as input
a sequence of tokens so very similar to
text classification
but the main twist is that
we have a cls token for the start but we
also have this separation token which
splits the question from the answer so
we basically concatenate
the question um with yet with sorry with
the context and then we feed these
together into this encoder
maybe you would like to explain the cls
token as well
yeah yeah sure sure so the cls token is
a special token um that's associated
with a tokenizer called workpiece so
that's actually in chapter six of the
course you can find all the details
about
how that how that really works but
for now you can just think of it as a
special token that we introduce to
indicate the start of a sequence of text
or a sequence of tokens it is sort of
like containing the class
basically like when you think about like
in a supervised manner it's it just
contains like information about the
class and stuff so it is that's where
cls itself comes from maybe
exactly yeah that's right so when you're
doing classification tasks
like say sentiment analysis or you know
as uh vincent was talking about last
week
um the other day
um
people often use the
representation of that cls token as the
thing that is the feature vector for
your classifier precisely for what you
said
and so each one of these tokens
will actually produce a vector
called a hidden state
and
these um these hidden states
um by themselves that you know they
don't have tons of information um at
this at the stage yet and so what we do
is we then feed them through a linear
layer which is just like a kind of sort
of fully connected
network attached to your encoder
and the the shape of that linear layer
is such that we can predict for every
token
what are the logits
or what is let's say the probability
that it is a start or an end
token associated with it with the answer
and so
every one of these tokens will have some
different
probability and hopefully when we train
the model it will learn to identify
which
pairs of tokens indicate the start and
the end and that's kind of what this
with this diagram is um communicating
and if we go kind of one layer deeper
then
what what we're really going to do
is we're going to take a sequence of
tokens like this
and you can see that each token gets two
labels it gets a star and an end label
and we will indicate
if the answer exists or if it's the
start we'll indicate it with a one so
you can see here that um the has
the the pink
label is one um to indicate that's the
start
and then here on this token here the end
label is one because that's you know
where the end of the answer is and so
the basic idea is we've got to somehow
take all of these tokens
assign them two labels start and end
and then train the model to work out um
where which which pairs of start and end
correspond to the
um to the answer
so
[Music]
let's have a look at how this kind of
first step works
how do we actually prepare our data to
do this well so here i'm just using
distilbert it's a very popular fast to
train model
but in general
any kind of invert like model would be
would be perfectly fine
and
what i'm going to do here is i just feed
in
the the question and the context as a
pair into the tokenizer
and so if we then decode this this input
we can see that we've now introduced the
cls token
and we've also got
a separation token here which is
splitting apart the question about the
virgin mary
from the
um the context where the answer might
exist
so this is kind of like similar to what
you probably saw in part one of the
course where we were looking at
kind of paraphrase um identification you
know trying to figure out if one
sentence is a paraphrase of another
um and here the thing that we're doing
is we're just providing two inputs to
the tokenizer which is a little bit
different to you know standard like
classification tasks
by the way we have like a couple of
questions can would you like to answer
them shortly i didn't want to interrupt
you no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
i think it's way more fun interrupting
because
otherwise it feels like i'm just talking
to like you know the void
um
so there's a question lewis you talked
about tf idea for the retriever how
about retrievers that use deep learning
like dpr do they outperform statistical
models by a lot do they impose some new
constraints this is not that uh relevant
to the context uh like
just yeah from the retriever yeah
yeah that's a great question so um
here
the question is about this part of the
sort of real world pipeline question
answering system
and what the
um question is about is there are
alternatives to using um kind of like
statistical approaches um based on
embeddings basically
and the the sort of super hot topic for
you know recent years has been something
called dense passage retrieval
yeah
or dpr
and um
the idea with this dense passage
retrieval is that you represent each one
of your documents as a as an embedding
vector and your query as an embedding
vector and then you kind of do like a
similarity score
on those two vectors
so
i from what i remember
dpr
was
like
sort of claiming that they had state of
the art on some retrieval tasks but i
know that niels reimer at hugging face
has a paper where he analyzed
the performance of dpr at different um
scales so like how many documents you
have and from what i remember if once
you start hitting like very very large
numbers of documents it's you're much
better off using um
a statistical method like tfidf or bm25
is the kind of modern one
um but i'll i'll put a link to the
papers in the discord later how is this
different from ms marco uh
passage ranking by the way just a quick
question
um
they look very familiar
yeah so
i actually don't know the answer between
what is the difference between ms marco
and dpr
i will check after after the stream i
will definitely check yeah
uh another question we have
gone through it but yeah what are some
useful metrics for the qa task and with
a quick explanation of how they work
please
and do we have a different metric for
information retrieval i think they are
different
yes
answer you can answer
yeah yeah so um with information
retrieval um the the sort of let's say
most common metrics that people use are
kind of like precision and recall um in
the sense that like
you want your retriever to return
documents that are relevant to the query
so that would be kind of
your precision in some sense
but you by the same token you want to
make sure that
if an answer exists that you actually
collected and so that's that's sort of
the recall side of of the equation
and
generally speaking um
there are things called like mean
absolute precision uh which is like a
twist on on the precision metric that
you're familiar with from classification
which basically tries to weight um the
the
the quality of the return documents or
say the relevance of the return
documents
um
in a way that uh is closer to you know
what a user would expect
and then for the reader or for the
actual reading comprehension task
the metrics we talked about were on
these papers with code so we have this
exact match metric
an exact match here just literally says
you know if i predict the exact um span
of text then this is plus one
and if i don't then it's zero
um and the f1 score here is is kind of
like a modified variant of f1 from
from classification
where your
basically you take your answer your
predicted answer and you chunk it into
like a bag of words
and then you compare the overlap of that
bag of words with the bag of words from
the ground truth and then you look for
the kind of you know how many of those
words overlap with the words in your um
in your ground truth and that gives you
a kind of like you know precision recall
type
when you think about it for this
like when you are doing f1 score in
the in the extractive question answering
you
the the the point where
f1 score might come wrong uh like might
come less
might be that your answer contains
some boundary words that i actually do
not belong to the answer
but i don't think like it would be the
opposite warrior i have never come
across that like where
the
answer
um
like answer is chopped or something like
the ground truth is chopped or something
i never come across that i just wanted
to say
yeah i think but i think what you said
right is that in general
the exact match score will generally be
less than the f1 um because of this
penalty right if you have a boundary
word you're just going to get zero um
whereas the f1 is a little bit more
forgiving um yeah actually
i would i would definitely use f1
instead because it's usually like
overrated you know exact match it's
yeah yeah
it's a tough one um do we have any more
questions or should we carry on with um
there is like small
questions so someone and hello i'm a
data scientist new here i want to learn
more about hugging face for now i'm
using a transformer between eraser razer
chatbot camembert i want to expand my
knowledge there any course you recommend
do you often do live workshops so
we are actually going through the
hugging face course you can find in hf
dot co slash course
and i've also done a chatbot with raza
using hugging face birth models
maybe
you would get more answer over there and
also raza's own hacking face pipeline
documentation just saying
awesome
there is
are there other token
you can label
as non-important texts i don't know
about this
so that question might be about this um
diagram where we we talked about that
for every token we're going to
assign a label of whether or not that
token belongs to the start or end of an
answer
so
in the question answering task that's
the only thing you have is just start
and end
but the answer to your question might be
more in the direction of like token
classification like maybe you're
interested in extracting different kind
or predicting different kinds of labels
for your for your tokens and so
if that's the case you might want to
check out the token classification
chapter we have
um here
so we we have vincent here and he's
saying got me curious
curious what is the intended use case
for these question answering models
yeah that's a great question so
the
probably the most
common one that i've seen in the wild
has been um
typically for like let's let's call it
like enterprise search so
um
you know no one really has access to
google in their company um but many
companies have a lot of documents
and so the first thing that at least
i've experienced is that you will
typically have a search engine
which will allow you to index all your
documents and that will give you let's
say
the first part of this equation the
retriever
um but then
you might want to ask like more
elaborate questions
for example maybe like things that are
quite domain specific and so even if
your retriever is giving you
let's say 10 documents
if these documents are say legal
documents
you still have to read you know through
those legal documents to find the answer
so i would say like
most of the current use cases are kind
of in this kind of like enterprise
settings from what i've seen
um and there is like a sort of nice
example of this
from a paper called quad
where
these researchers at berkeley and
elsewhere they pointed out that in in
sort of legal contract review there's a
very tedious
process involved in kind of extracting
systematically answers to some common
questions about legal contracts
and so
they point out that like this is like a
task that you know typically requires
some law interns to spend their whole
summer
working through documents it's kind of
boring but everyone does it because you
need that domain knowledge
and at least in this paper they sort of
provide a data set to try and help
future legal scholars
build such a system that would um
you know simplify that extraction
process
um i don't know if that answers the
question vincent but i'm happy to have
to you know talk about it on discord
later
so in like i can i can make an edition
if you'd like
different
uh so in my previous job uh like
question answering also in itself the is
divided into open book question
answering clause but question answering
as well uh and in my previous job what
we did was that we had this very big
researcher team
and those researcher team
was extracting this is like an entity
extraction kind of thing but it was
solved through question answering that's
at least that's what i have discovered
where
they had to like extract so many
repetitive information from research
papers
so i also used tried using that one
these are i feel like there is so many
ways like so many combinations that you
can model information retrieval and
question answering is also used very
widely
and uh someone heiko who is
who is by the way he's doing he's from
aws
doing many nice notebooks for hugging
face plus aws
so he said imagine you have to deal with
a lot of text of the same structure you
can use qa models to retrieve k key from
in k info from your dogs what is the
start date for this contract like just
what you have said
yeah and vincent said sure but if if you
have lots of contracts wouldn't entity
detection on the date
be a more pragmatic approach
i feel like this is more often
that falls more into a named entity
recognition where you can solve with the
tools like duckling
where it extracts
dates uh email
names etc and vincent asks what is the
intended use case as in
at what practical tasks
do qa systems neural qa systems make a
lot of sense practically today
i would say
where your answer is not exactly
passing
um like where your question is asked
differently than uh your tech your
context is
uh exactly said you know like
questions are not
or are not um asked perfectly sometimes
uh for given in the context so i would
say
if your question is not perfectly asked
you know with maybe synonyms and stuff
and neural systems might actually work
but this is my opinion
yeah and and maybe just just to sort of
add another comment there is that you
know with entity extraction methods like
um
you know a lot of a lot of the things
that question answering provides is the
ability to get like a span of text and
you know i can do the same thing with an
entity recognition system i can you know
kind of reconstruct a span given some
entities
um
but yeah maybe the trade-off is like how
much post-processing do i need to do or
how many rules do i need to introduce to
kind of combine for example you know
um the elements of an address together
or something um but that's yeah in terms
of like practical use is probably the
the length of the answer is maybe the
interesting thing
yeah like because it has this pen itself
as a future like built in that's
actually nice
omar asks can you do qa from data such
as tables or websites
uh yes you can so
right there's a famous model now called
tapas
um let's see this is probably
from this one from google oh we don't
have a widget is that right
uh
i don't know for tapas if we have it
it's like
sorry
so yeah you can kind of do this here's a
question how many stars does the
transformers repository have here's a
table and you can compute and it then
extracts this
um
but you know talking to niels who's the
guy who implemented this in the
transformers library i mean
this is like a sledgehammer right
on uh on top of a
of a task that you can probably solve
with like you know one line of excel or
pandas
um
but i i think you know it's it's more a
question of maybe in the future we start
entering an interesting sort of space
where you know asking natural language
questions over very large tables um is
kind of interesting
so
another question is how does qa really
relate to neural search can we say that
the letter is qa applied to different
types of data like pictures visual
question answering i guess
yeah i think neural search is kind of an
umbrella term it's probably maybe
not as well defined as like things like
i mean it's probably like data science
you know what is data science um and i
think in the neural search domain
you could sort of say that anything
that's kind of relying you know on
neural networks in some capacity
is is probably under that umbrella term
um so if you're just using retrieval
with dpr that's probably neural search
and yeah question answering would be a
subset um because it's you know the
whole domain is also for images right i
mean there's a
there's a company called gina which does
a lot of nice
um search
stuff and let's see they have
um
where are these examples so if you
look at these examples they have okay
this is change this allah saw it but
basically this is like the ability to
search on images on audio i think a
little bit and also on um
you know text so
it's it's a very big umbrella term
shall we uh last question there is so
much questions but
let's take one last one because people
took my jokes
but it's fun
yeah i mean
i think i think today i would be happy
if we just sort of also just chat and do
these things and you know all the code
is in the in the course so you can
always look at it later
so is there a multilingual approach for
question answering yet for example a
customer in amazon could ask a question
in spanish for which an answer does not
exist yet in the spanish language in
amazon but answer could exist in the in
international english amazon
ah that's a good question so if we're
talking about the extractive
case
then
the answer would probably be no um for
example if i have
um if i ask a question
and my if we go back to our trusty
picture if i ask a question in spanish
and all my documents are in german
then you know the retriever's not going
to have a do a great job at finding
first of all relevant documents but the
reader if it was only trained for german
text
is going to have a very tough time
figuring out how that question relates
to the to the context
um
so
what you could do is you could translate
on the fly so if you if you wanted to
take
your question you could translate it
into the target language that would be
one thing to do
um the alternative thing to do would be
to take um like a
multilingual
kind of model like let's say xlm roberta
and this is a kind of
very good starting point if your
language belongs to one of the hundred
languages that it was pre-trained on so
this is just like a bert like model or a
roberta model but it's multilingual so
you can then fine-tune it on um on say
your german documents
um and then if you get uh sort of if you
have spanish documents as well then in
principle it will do relatively okay on
those as well but the performance is
you know much
more dependent on sort of the
differences of the languages so
at least when i've worked with xlm
r
if you have languages that are very
different from the language you
fine-tuned on the performance drops
pretty
catastrophically
i would actually say this is one of the
cases where um like if you after you
translate it it's better to use uh
something that is like
similarity based instead of direct q a
as like this is just an opinion and an
instinct i don't i'm not i i have a
little bit of experience with this
but yeah i don't know if i'm right but i
i just
felt like it
um
another one are these
any are there any use cases papers that
talk about were given a document what
are the questions that could be answered
by this document there is a map
that's a great question
um it's question generation sort of i
see yeah i was thinking about you know
like t5 and stuff
um
yeah
yeah so i i think
i i can't remember off the top of my
head of of the papers that do this but
i've definitely seen um examples where
people
you frame the problem as a kind of
sequence to sequence problem so
you say here's my document and here's
like a candidate question so you have to
build your own training set for this and
then if you train a model like t5 on
such a corpus
then the model will it's kind of like a
translation task right it's kind of like
your language is like your document and
your target language is the the
questions and then once you've trained
this model you can then in principle
feed it new uh documents and then
generate new questions
um but
i think the question that this person is
asking is actually deeper than that it's
like just given a document
um
maybe it's more possible questions right
yeah and that that that's like a that's
a i think almost a impossible i've
i've looked up in the paper papers with
code and it tells what you have said but
i i swear
i saw it somewhere that it says
we're
generating no it's generating answer
candidates anyway i'm going to find it
and i'm going to post it on my twitter
at some point
well you know what like why don't we try
okay let's see how t0 plus plus can
handle this
um
so
maybe let's take a bit of text
that we've got here from wikipedia
so this is this uh
text about the virgin mary
and let's feed it as the context
and then maybe we can ask
what questions
can be asked about this
text
i would be simple for this
oh okay
what is the name of the name of the
statue for mary oh it did
yeah okay
i love t0 for some reason it's so good
and it did
yeah i mean
it doesn't give us all of them
maybe
maybe like if you could specify like
five of them maybe provide like
list of questions about this
um text
i don't know what it will do
now okay i think it's a bit stuck in its
uh local minima yeah but
yeah
um
question
there is so many questions what is an
effective way to go from a passage to a
question in other words generate a
reasonable question we just covered it
yeah
uh we got some good feedback some people
agree with it you should do more of
these events often i agree
i like spending time with luis a lot
uh do you recommend doing a language
model fine tune before qa for these
multi-lingual like if you are going to
do multi-dingual things are you do you
recommend doing a language model i don't
know
yeah so i think it depends on on your
target language um so so one thing that
i typically recommend you do first if it
exists right so
let's suppose i have documents in german
um
so
deep set
um
which is another question answering
or neural search company they have a
bunch of different models and i think
from memory they have like
did they fine tune
okay maybe they didn't have one or maybe
it's g bird yeah here we go
okay this is just the base model but
basically what i wanted to say was that
um
if you can find a model that has been
fine-tuned already on on squad in your
target language that is probably a good
baseline to start with
um because you know even though these
squad models have tons of well-known
problems like you know they're not
really learning
like how to answer questions they take
shortcuts all the time
um they often do provide a good starting
point for building a system so
you know once you have this squad model
you can at least improve it by
fine-tuning a base model on your own
target corpus
um
for the whole like generic multilingual
case i'm not aware of like many kind of
fine-tuned like general multilingual
models so generally you will have to do
something like take excellent rebecca as
your base and then fine-tune it on your
your own corpus
um
the the challenge i've often seen is
that um the labeling of data for this is
very painful because
you know we see here that i need to
provide
um
like the span of text where
the answer occurs i need to index this
and you know there are companies that
will help you
do that but it's also
a kind of known problem how you generate
the questions is quite a tough task
um so
yeah short answer i think you'll
generally have to fine-tune the model
and
the sad answer is that unless you're
lucky enough to belong to one of these
hundred languages that are covered by
say excellent roberta then you're going
to have to
get pretty clever with regular
expressions and
you know build a non-neural
approach
bender rule
yeah
um
a question for marvi which relates to
previous
stream about sentiments and by ucs are
there any work being done currently to
tackle biases in qa is by seeing qa
being explored i think this is more of a
question for vincent
yeah i think i've never seen it
yes it's a very good question though
because i mean you could imagine that
huh i'm just thinking like
the bias that might exist
that's an interesting one
i'm just thinking about like if the
question if the question has like for
example a certain name
maybe the most likely answer that is
predicted
is not the one we want but i don't know
i'm not sure maybe vincent can
um it's maybe like if you you can
actually like do find uh biases
by testing it like for instance you have
these
uh context text
where it is saying something bad about
you know like it says something good
about one race of people and it says
something about bad about some race and
then you can ask a question and see
which race it's got like about a race
and which race it's going to return
maybe something like that
yeah yeah i think
yeah and i think it's it's probably
actually now i'm thinking about it it's
probably a similar bias question that we
might associate with like other types of
let's say search engines so like yeah
you know if i
if i type something into google and it
starts giving me a very skewed set of
results based on you know some personal
um characteristics
you know that's not great so
what i said was like for open book
question answering where you are given
the context but for close book question
answering which is something like what
google does i guess in the
in the
yeah yeah yeah you know a search engine
and it is it does actually return bad
things about like people i remember like
what is the worst indian accent
returning something
uh what is the ugliest one something
like that i don't want to offend anyone
but it was something that i have
literally
seen so in models like t5
maybe you could actually come across
that
[Music]
let's ask t0 is the world flat
so
i mean maybe that's an example right
like here we've asked a closed model um
for some
answer and that's a bias right it's uh
or at least it's wrong
um
you know maybe maybe if t0 is trained on
tons of internet text there's probably
tons of you know flat earth um blog
posts that it's uh picking up on anyway
um um
regarding dealing with imbalanced data
set if i have the same same case but
with array of tokens and array of tags
like for example ncbi disease how would
the proposed approach change
that's that's a
that's a great question it's one that
actually the reason i had this quad
paper was precisely for that reason
so
um
let me show you where it is so one thing
that can happen
when you do
extractive question answering
is that um
the
if you have like
let's suppose i have a piece of text and
the answer doesn't exist in that text so
this this can happen you know imagine
that
um i have a question like about the
virgin mary and maybe my retriever has
given me a document about you know
mary some pop artist or something
so clearly there's no relevance in terms
of the question and the answer there and
what the question answering models um
will predict is what's called the empty
span so they should typically say we
predict nothing for this um for this
answer for this for this question
and
sometimes what can happen is that if
your documents are very long you'll have
to split them into many different
passages
and you'll end up having a very
imbalanced setup where the vast majority
of
the the passages don't have an answer
relevant to the question and so the
model will actually get the same kind of
problems you have in text classification
where you end up predicting the empty
span most of the time
so the trick that people typically do
here is kind of like a down waiting so
this is sort of very similar to like
um when you are doing text
classification you might apply some
kind of penalty or some weight factor
on the examples that are
you know in the majority class
but yeah basically you do need to deal
with this
in practice because
the model will just get really good at
predicting the most common feature
let's see so we have five minutes
mermaid
and
i didn't do any code but we had some fun
talking about things
maybe i know there was a question in
discord about domain adaptation
and maybe we could just talk about that
for a few minutes
what do you think
sure sorry my mic was closed
um
by the way victor victor is here and he
said oops for the t-zero
okay
so maybe just to wrap up with a last set
of questions that um so one thing i was
telling you before is that if you have
access to a kind of fine-tuned squad
model um
you know you should uh
like just use it as your baseline
and um
this will
generally be okay as long as the text
you're dealing with is kind of similar
to squad which is based on wikipedia so
these are like very factual
based articles
but you know if you're doing something
that is very different
then the performance will be really bad
so
there's a there's a nice paper
um called sub
qa
which is a data set of subjectivity and
review comprehension
by these people in denmark
and
what they were looking at were
what is the impact
when you've got kind of subjective
reviews of products on amazon
and you know this is like much harder
thing to to measure because subjectivity
is a little bit in the domain of let's
say sentiment you know we don't really
have clear
rigorous ways of quantifying that
but the interesting thing that i want to
point your attention to is that
they
they took kind of off-the-shelf models
so what you can see in green here
um is bert um fine-tuned on squad
so you can see that on squad bert gets a
really high score
but then when you try to apply it to
these different
reviews of different products
on amazon which were specifically
curated for this subjectivity
you can see that the performance is like
abysmal right so suddenly you go from
having an f1 score of like 80 or 90
points down to like you know 20 or below
um and so what they
observe in this particular paper is that
if you take your squad model and then
you fine tune it a little bit more on
the domain data
then you recover
or you get a significant boost in your
performance so you can see that here the
grocery score for burp with no just out
of the box squad is below 25 points
and then once they um fine-tune on the
in-domain data they're able to you know
roughly double this
this performance
and so this is probably the last like
sort of thing to mention is that um
you know question answering is is a much
more complicated beast than than you
know say classification and
classification is already hard enough so
you will have to experiment a little bit
on how how do you get the best
performance out of these models
i hope that answers that question
yeah
um we can continue the discussion in
discord like if you have any questions
you can ask in general event chat room
and
we should definitely do this more often
next week we can maybe like continue a
little with the question answering and
then move on to another task
yeah i think i think the most voted one
after question answering was
pre-training or training from scratch
and i think that would be a fun one to
to talk about and maybe talk about some
of the challenges that um one runs into
thank you so much
thanks and thanks everyone for the
questions um
pleasure and um